the beauty of living in the bush is
great for 99.9% of the time but there's
that 0.1% that comes up every few years
it's pretty bloody scary and it's up to
each individual responsibility to have
their house really well prepared because
it's a volunteer I'm really upset I've
been to a lot of houses we get there we
can't get in
we gotta get the truck in the bloody
driveway cause it's full of rubbish
they've got a little tiny bit of water
how can we fight a fire for them you
can't so it sounds like it's an
extremely frustrating situation for you
in that case things like that and not
making your job any easier when you're
trying to deal with the fire no heater
at all it makes it really dangerous
because all of a sudden we could be in a
situation that can be overrun by fire in
minutes I'm talking less admit it you
can go from oh it's a pretty little fire
to life-threatening and it's just yeah
the main thing is just get get us out
again and how difficult is it for
residents there we know that they're
being urged to evacuate the area are
people listening to that or are they
still wanting to stay there to try to
protect their home in this particular
area there's less than a hundred homes
all up and I think there's probably 10
or 15 homes that have presidents who are
staying to protect their own property
but they are very well prepared and
their properties are all very well
prepared most the other people who
didn't go through all that trouble
themselves and their life shot through
and they leave it up to me
and how many of you are there people
like you who have volunteer firefighters
who are then turning out to try to help
contain these fires to be honest I don't
know that speak thousands because they
are from all over Australia thanks
people thanks a lot it must be a very
difficult time for you and a huge deal
of good work that's being done by people
like you and all the other volunteers
there it must be a terrifying time for
local people yeah it is I can't sleep
you all my life I've been volunteer
firefighter 15 years I was in a couple
of situation the last couple of days and
I was terrified what about those fears
as to what could happen next with this
we know that there are these three major
fires and the feeling is that they could
join together to create this mega fire
look I haven't seen any TV news nothing
for the last I think someone said
today's five days apparently I just lost
track of time
I have seen the fire maps coming through
from the fire service yeah while I'm
working I've lived in the mountains all
of my life yeah it could possibly happen
and if it does happen there will be
major catastrophe it will be absolutely
what's in the background here will be
nothing and paint a picture for us then
what it's like being a volunteer
firefighter what it's like seeing that
fire all around you in an area you live
in an area you obviously love and feel
strongly about
so I'm smiling because of the
camaraderie that I've had developed
which people have just met in the last
few days I had a volunteer firefighter
ring me up today and say thank you for
my hospitality
I couldn't believe the guy when I'm so
indebted to him for having saved my
house it's just they're amazing people
that they're all absolutely amazing
people and they do it for free